what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today it looks like we have a lot of
news about Spider-Man specifically Tom
Holland Spider-Man staying in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so today we'll go
over the new contract he reportedly
signed what his upcoming Spider-Man
movies are exactly going to be about and
his major role that he is going to play
in the next new Avengers films now the
first thing that we'll talk about is the
report that states Tom Holland has
signed a new deal in secret now you
might have heard about this yesterday
but we're going to break down what
exactly this means now for starters if
you do not recall right after Spider-Man
no way home came out Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios and
executive producer Amy Pascal came out
and said that they are already working
on the next Spider-Man film they told us
this they said so we don't have to worry
about Spider-Man leaving the MCU like we
had to do a few years ago there was a
new contract that was being negotiated
between Sony and Disney slash Marvel
Studios and for a long time there looked
like Spider-Man was going to be taken
out of the MCU because you have to
remember Sony does own the movie rights
to Spider-Man if Sony wants Spider-Man
out of the MCU unfortunately he comes
out but Sony and Marvel told us hey you
don't have to worry we're already
working on the next Spider-Man film and
so according to a new report from
Insider my time to shine hello who has a
great track record she says that Tom
Holland signed his new deal it's a huge
deal and he signed it in secret now the
secret part that is pretty expected they
don't typically sign a deal and then go
announce it what they're most likely
going to do is just simply announce a
new Spider-Man trilogy whenever
cinemacon is coming up in April and Sony
always has a big presence there also
Sony is confirmed to be attending this
year and it is from April 24th through
April 27th so sometime between those
dates we could not for sure but we could
be getting a Spider-Man announcement now
as far as what this new deal for Tom
Holland is my time to shine hello did
not say however we have gotten reports
in the past asked what it most likely
would be and that is a deal for three
Spider-Man movies and three team-up
films so obviously the next Spider-Man
trilogy the Spider-Man titled film
starring Tom Holland and possibly
Zendaya and Jacob battle on they said
they want to come back but that's not
confirmed yet but those will be
specifically focused on Spider-Man and
his life while obviously The Avengers
ones will be focused on The Avengers
they'll focus on King and of course the
Multiverse then there's another one out
there if it is indeed for six different
projects then one project we don't know
but it is supposed to be a team up
project so this could be for a Disney
Plus show like Daredevil or he could
appear in another movie that is unsure
right now but if we hear anything we'll
of course do an update now as far as
what the Spider-Man trilogy and what Tom
Holland's role in The Avengers films are
going to be we actually do have a little
bit of information about that we also
might know when exactly to expect the
actual release date for Spider-Man 4.
The Insider my time to shine hello low
has also tweeted that Tom Holland is
going to be the lead in Avengers Kang
Dynasty and honestly to me this makes a
lot of sense in fact even Anthony Mackey
the new Captain America who some people
thought would lead the new Avengers team
has even cast doubts on Sam being the
new leader of the new Avengers in a
recent interview with Empire magazine
the interview asked when the Avengers
come back they'll need a leader do you
think that Sam Wilson could be that guy
in which he replied I think he's not
Steve Rogers and I think that's a good
thing because to me this new cap is
Rocky he's going to be the underdog in
any situation he's not a super soldier
he's not a hundred years old he doesn't
have the Avengers what happens with this
guy who announces publicly kind of
without the support I'm new Captain
America what happens next I think is
fascinating because he's a guy he's a
guy with wings and a shield but he is a
guy so even Anthony Mackey here is kind
of hinting that the new Captain America
is exactly that he's new and won't
exactly be leading the new Avengers team
however people do know Spider-Man he has
been around for a while and keep in mind
that people still know the Avengers
still know Spider-Man they may not know
Peter Parker per se they may not know
who Spider-Man is under the mask but
people still know who Spider-Man is so
the Avengers who fought with Spider-Man
Doctor Strange everybody they're still
going to have all of the memories that
they've had with Spider-Man in the past
they simply don't know that he is Peter
Parker so Spider-Man can still come in
and be a leader because everybody knows
him now we do know a little bit about
how Avengers the King Dynasty Spider-Man
4 and Avengers Secret Wars is kind of
going to go down my time to shine hello
has also tweeted that Spider-Man 4 will
come out before Secret Wars so I'm
assuming it's not going to come out
before the Kang Dynasty because she
would have said it's going to come out
before the King Dynasty but she
specifically said it's coming out before
Avengers Secret Wars so it looks like
the order is going to be the King
Dynasty Spider-Man 4 and then sacred
Wars and I'm assuming the new Avengers
will kind of be like the old Avengers as
well yes Captain America was the leader
but Iron Man was kind of a co-leader as
well so Spider-Man may be the new leader
but I am also assuming that doctor
strange is going to be by his side as
well which makes sense because doctor
strange doesn't seem like the type of
person who would want to lead the
Avengers he kind of would probably want
to do his own thing but if there are
threats to reality and our world out
there he obviously needs to be involved
however Doctor Strange was never really
teaming up with the Avengers until
Avengers Infinity War whereas Spider-Man
has been there since Civil War plus I'm
assuming that the Hulk is going to be
there he'll help Spider-Man out as well
and hopefully Thor shows up as well but
as far as who is going to be an actual
leader I do think Spider-Man is the best
choice so in the Kang Dynasty it's
mostly going to be pretty grounded
Avengers Doctor Strange Captain America
Ant-Man the Hulk maybe the Scarlet Witch
depending on what her story is like
maybe a few others but keep in mind
there are a lot of other teams that are
in space that'll probably come during
Secret Wars not the King Dynasty so
they're going to deal with King but then
they're going to realize that this is
much bigger than just one Kang and
they'll most likely have to deal with
more than one variant and also keep in
mind the Fantastic Four are probably
going to be dealing with King as well
and maybe they show up in the King
Dynasty but for sure they are going to
be in secret Wars because the Avengers
team that takes on Kang and all of his
variants in secret Wars isn't just going
to be kind of one team it's going to be
a lot of teams combined much like we saw
in Avengers end game and Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four is going to be a
key in secret Wars because he is
probably going to know more about the
Multiverse than anyone maybe even more
than doctor strange after all those Kang
portals that teleport them seem to look
a lot like Reed Richard's portal and
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness and Kang whose real name is
Nathaniel Richards is supposed to be a
descendant of Reed Richards Mr Fantastic
so the first Avengers film is going to
be Tom Holland Spider-Man as the leader
with probably Doctor Strange by his side
but the secret Wars Avengers team is
going to be much different both most
likely led by a few people Spider-Man
Doctor Strange Reed Richards maybe even
Captain Marvel depending on what happens
during the Marvels maybe even some
leaders like Professor Xavier from other
universes could be involved as well
which I hope they are regardless of what
happens the future for Marvel Studios is
so exciting and I'm really glad that Tom
Holland continues to be a part of it but
it does sound like this probably is
going to be the last contract deal that
Tom Holland signs because according to
The Insider film Odyssey Miles Morales
is supposed to be introduced in
Spider-Man 4. a lot of fans have really
been looking forward to this myself
included but this does look like it
might mean the end of Tom Holland
Spider-Man being the main Spider-Man in
the MCU if this deal that he signed is
what we think it is that means he's
going to appear in over 11 or 12
different Marvel movies and projects
that is a lot for one character over
time and Tom Holland has expressed that
he doesn't want to play Spider-Man
forever so Miles Morales being
introduced in Spider-Man 4 if that is
true could be a sign that Miles Morales
could be the new Spider-Man of the
future his popularity has really grown
after into the spider-verse and I think
that this would be a really good idea it
keeps things fresh and Miles Morales is
an awesome Spider-Man and so far that's
what we know about Spider-Man's future
in the MCU if we hear anything else of
course we'll be sure to do an update
video on it so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news don't
forget to like the video and leave your
thoughts about this video in the
comments down below you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof